Ese es su indicativo militar necesitan
cruzar este pantano para llegar a los
restos de un soldador ruso
los hombres dicen que su cámara diría
ayuda porque su trabajo es sombrío a
recoger los cadáveres enemigos que yacen
por la región de harquiff después de un
kilómetro llegan al lugar
vinimos aquí antes y nos llevamos todos
los cuerpos que pudimos cargar ahora
hemos vuelto por el quinto como pueden
ver no queda mucho de él estaba herido
tiene torniquetes en las piernas solo la
mitad del cuerpo está aquí los perros
probablemente se comieron la otra mitad
o lo arrastraron
con los primeros cuerpos que encontramos
por supuesto que tuvo una reacción
emocional como la tendría cualquiera
pero una vez que has cargado con 100 o
más las emociones desaparecen
todos los cuerpos que hemos encontrado
estamos dispuestos a entregarlos a
cambio de los nuestros solo imploro a
sus familiares que inicien un movimiento
de protesta
la esperanza es que una mayor conciencia
sobre el elevado número de víctimas
pueda conducir a un menor apoyo a la
guerra en Rusia sin embargo los
principales objetivos de la recogida de
cadáveres son impedir que contaminen el
medio ambiente aportar pruebas para
futuros juicios por crímenes de guerra y
lo que es más importante
intercambiarlos por los cuerpos de
soldados ucranianos primero los llevamos
a la morgue después del proceso de
identificación los llevamos a los
vagones
este vagón de ferrocarril contiene
actualmente 10 cadáveres de soldados
rusos serán intercambiados dentro de
unos días
qué siento por ellos
no siento nada son cadáveres y ya está
yuris ya ha recogido a más de 400 rusos
muertos Aunque dan cientos más por
encontrar solo en la región de